yeah what's up guys hi it's Kate this is
Dave fails we are back at all things
comedy I am not reading any commercials
today which I'm kind of I'm kind of okay
with I'm kind of excited usually I read
a big long commercial at the top today
the commercial is for your book the
commercial today is for my guests
you guys I'm super pumped to have you
first of all you're stunning you're
you're so pretty I met you at the comedy
store what like two weeks ago or
something for the lighting in there is
fantastic so I felt like a probably
looked extra pretty with super dark and
dingy and there's like this is great
lighting to meet someone new
the lighting is fantastic cuz you can
barely see anyone is what you're saying
dude the lighting backstage at the
Comedy Store they have this huge like
vanity mirror with all these bright
lights on it it is the best selfie light
like oh it's like the loom a the little
yeah I don't know if you have one but I
do for what I'm out and about at night
and this thing is like a beam of laser
beautiful soft lighting and I mean it's
bright yeah out somewhere everyone's
eyes are like dilating afterwards you
mean the Loom a case on your cell phone
like yeah it's like a ring light for
your cell phone for people that don't
know that aren't like in show business
like a lot of actresses will make you
have a ring light on set when you're
doing like an interview like I once
heard a story of these guys went to
interview Pamela Anderson at her house
and they forgot to bring a ring light
she's like I am sorry I can't go on
camera without that's fantastic yeah I
love that kind of tenacity like there's
a girl that was in the business with me
in the 90s her name is Janine very
famous girl from the 90s Janine
Lindemulder and and she would only be
shot by one side of her face so even if
it was like a driving scenario and they
wanted her driving she's like I can
drive the car because then you'll be
shooting me from my wrong side so her
whole career was over here so when you
kind of see her straight on or in person
she gets a break I gave her a little
privacy in a weird way but right oh
there she wouldn't even let him shoot
her from the front everything was from
the side she always turned her face this
way that is so funny like herself shot
straight on can you imagine well first
of all okay I haven't even said who you
are so my guest today history isn't
mystery guest for people watching they
already know for people listening this
could just
forever and who the [ __ ] are they
watching live well no no this isn't live
I could do that spoil it for you guys no
i-i've done live in the past but then
sometimes people blurt things out that
they're like oh [ __ ] I shouldn't have
said that so now I know sure like when
you give away your home address by
accident I've done that yep done that so
my guest today is fabulous you could
know her from so many things you know
many things were a URR and were a
massive star in the adult industry yeah
would you say the Sarah Palin thing is
what made you a huge name there were two
things that happen at the same time it
was the milf genre becoming the most
widely recognized and sought-after genre
in the business which is and then the
second thing was Palin so they both
happen at the same time and it was just
a game changer for my life for for
traveling you know I got to do it go to
DC with Larry Flynt and sit with him
while he talked and and I got to have
all these incredible experience and
experienced went to Finland is Sarah
Palin I was on all these busses in
Finland I was like wow so crazy it was
like this level of Fame that I never
thought I would get from porn that I
never really wanted but once it happened
I was like I was so in it's fine it's
fine I was 35 at the time so I was old
enough to really be like you know what
this is gonna be your last good run Lisa
use am that is a sport yeah everything
you can on other people's dime you know
like travel travel hell yeah that's what
I do it's amazing and now you're an
author you have a book called the life
which looks amazing and she brought me a
copy of it and I'm really excited to
read it and you have a sports radio show
on XM correct yep I do fantasy sports on
Sirius XM fantasy sports radio I do my
own show every Monday night called Lisa
and does fantasy we cover football
basketball baseball a little bit of
hockey a little bit of golf and then I
do a show on Saturdays which is two
hours straight of nothing but fantasy
baseball yes guys my guess is Lisa Anne
at the real Lisa and on all social media
yes
I'm so happy that you're here it's so
great to be here it's hilarious because
first of all I had to I was researching
you you know
oh hi Brenton Breton Biddle comb just
walk well it's a name it sounds like a
porn name it does you could Brendon is a
porn star porn star and comedian
actually comedians for two years like I
don't know he's cute you know I could
seem in some milf movies because he can
be the pool boy
Brenton you could be the pool guys
Breton is the the man who does social
media for all things comedy any
Salieri's comedian and I hope that the
tapes that you're gonna put up is us
talking about how you could do porn
because that would be perfect do hope
that you should post this tape coz we
could you know we could entertain some
votes you guys we're just gonna keep
talk at aghori we're gonna keep talking
about how Brenton would be an amazing
cool boy in a porn scene until he posts
it on the all things comedy Instagram
the podcast is on hold until don't you
think Lisa I do I do it you know I have
a good eye for these kinds of but
Britain we're gonna need you to take
your dick out to be sure oh damn you
missed that part all right sorry you are
doing porn your dick was out the studio
early yes Ari Shaffir
Ari Shaffir his dick was out it's that's
a whole other channel let's get back to
to this so first of all I have to laugh
because I went to your Wikipedia which
is you know I'm a real you know
journalist obviously I research
Wikipedia that's like the only site I
read when I read up on people now can I
ask you something is your Wikipedia page
correct I don't even have a Wikipedia I
know everyone gives me [ __ ] my my
manager has been like why haven't you
had someone create and I'm like I don't
know I just never think of doing it it
never crossed my mind
don't worry about it you don't want it
you know why cuz people can go on there
and change it and they do crazy [ __ ] to
your page so if you don't go back and
check check it once a week and try to
get some key you're not allowed to
update your own page you have to get
someone else to the page so if you
yourself write in to defend a fact that
is not true it can't be done
so you have to have this friend that's
like your friend on Facebook that likes
to watch your back you know and does
these rants for you and you to have your
friend go on there like I forget and
it'll be like a
month and then I'll go back on there I'm
like oh I wonder how long this has been
up there it is weird like I found a
celebrity birthday site or something
that had my birthday totally wrong on
there like why we're on the celebrity
site so there's beauty in this as well I
was in Kansai oh my god celebrity
birthday so I never run good celebrity
list though I'm on like dumb [ __ ] like a
birthday page where my birthday is wrong
or I'm on some site for celebrity feet
where it's just like every photo I've
ever posted that my feet are and they
put it up there like that's that's all
that that's all I'm on I'm not on a good
list yeah it's a very select list that
you're on not one that you would put you
and not one that you could use as like
hey can you add these things to my
appearance when I go out on stage the
Comedy Store like I'm now on you know
celebrity best feet like no you can't do
that oh my god it's so embarrassing I
was just telling a friend the other day
that one of my credits on my IMDB is the
office because I had a line on an
episode of the office but then my line
got cut out so in the show I'm just an
extra but it's on my IMDB so when they
go to comedy clubs a lot of times
they'll put the office as a credit on
all my you know that ads for the show
they're like either going to Wikipedia
and imbd
and then I show up and then people come
up to me after after my shows they go oh
my god I'm such a huge fan of the office
but I can't remember who you were who
were you and I have to be like um I just
I was in the background seeing you know
like it's so embarrassing so anyway um
but so I was reading your Wikipedia and
there are probably lots of things on
there that are real and fake now that
you said that I'm super curious but the
me to the one thing that popped out I
was laughing about it was talking about
your opinions on dating athletes yeah
and and uh and you said why is this
Wikipedia worthy he ever wonder this uh
well I believe dating athletes is worthy
of everything I love athletes I'm very
into athletes but here's the thing you
had a quote on there where you said like
people people give me [ __ ] or whatever
about dating athletes but to me it's
like a guy who date's a Victoria's
Secret model like why wouldn't you date
an athlete what I've literally said
verbatim on this show so when I read
that I was like oh my
I have to because it is crazy to me that
anyone thinks it's weird that a girl
would be attracted
I completely agree thank you it's just
the same double standard we've dealt
with with men for years right and and it
is for me there's many reasons why with
athletes but if you look at the fact
that still after two and a half years of
retirement girl I am still the number
one most sought-after porn star in the
business you are I just reached a
billion views on just one site that's
only been up for ten years so that means
if you really did the numbers right I
have probably eight billion views it's
probably the fact of the entire globe
you know the population so take that
factoid and think I should be able to
watch a game and cherry-pick the hot
young talent from hell yeah game and
reach out to him and connect and also
athletes aren't gonna stalk and kill me
they're not gonna fall in love and
harass me they're just having sex with
other people that's the whole beauty but
it's not exclusive it's honest it's real
I tell them don't get wrapped up with a
girl she's gonna try and have your
athlete baby just wants your athlete
baby you know paycheck like you know and
so what is wrong with it I mean it's a
bizarre it's a bizarre thing and if
you've read down lower what was even
bigger news on my Wikipedia page was
when I went to a Knicks game with a 19
year old Notre Dame football player and
this this was a story that it went down
like this we took a picture of the game
I posted on my insta that night was over
the next day I wake up to my phone just
being blown up you know you got TMZ in
your phone you've got all these other
news wires in your phone and all my
friends like you're trending on Twitter
and I'm like this is weird let me get
into reality I go and check it I realize
like oh weird guys can date 19 year old
girls at any age yeah but when I did it
Notre Dame wanted to invoke policy on
him because because Notre Dame is a
Catholic school they're not supposed to
be having premarital sex oh my god in
the college rape generation of 2017
we're still talking about consensual sex
don't we have bigger fish to fry and so
this was it was such a big issue there
were sports commentators jumping in and
saying he should be thrown off the
football team like
it was such an ordeal and the whole
tides insane I was like he's of legal
age it was his choice we went to a
Knicks game also you're at a Knicks game
you how do they even know you had sex
you could have gone to a Knicks game and
not even hooked up very true I'm friends
with lots of hot guys that I have not
slept to us but I can't pass up a 19
year old really honest no love them
young I love him all ages but the thing
with young is there's just this fear
factor where they won't push the limit
they won't they won't over text you they
won't ask you too many questions so far
I'm happy for the moment they're just
grateful you know it's funny that you're
saying that because I've had a few
younger guys in fact recently there was
one that was like 25 and he's so hot and
so good but those twenty five to twenty
eight year olds they're like they're
just still so excited about [ __ ] and
they're just they go forever and they're
just well you get to hook up with porn
guys all the time which we had anymore
since I retired well that's their
special embed as well but I mean like
these young guys they worship you oh and
not only that they recover quickly so
let's say you go round one and you're
like you know how about a snack you know
what I mean like how little bites eat
maybe watch would you like a cookie
like what do you watch you can do it
again you can't do that with a guy my
eight I was laughing about that because
I so I went out a few times with this
guy I say one out hooked up a few times
with this guy he was 20 I think it's 26
actually but it doesn't matter the point
is at the time I had been dating a guy
who was like 40 and so when I would
sleep at the forty year old you know be
one time and then he'd be like ready to
go to sleep
the 26 25 year old whatever it was the
first time we had sex like 10 minutes
later he's like you want to go again and
I was like oh my god I forgot guys can
do this that's the true value right
there that's the true buy it is
maximizing your hangout time you have
that extra cardio you know a little
late-night romp is a little extra cardio
in the day having an orgasm also burned
some nice amount of calories and it also
lubricate your joints did you know
there's chemical release when you orgasm
okay I know it lubricates at least one
region my friends are walking does it
really in real life yeah that's why
that's why self-stimulation is so
healthy for people and that's why it's
such a big deal in hospitals and in
nursing homes where they still do want
to use some devices like flesh lights
were initially tried in hospitals with
with bets and and disabled men who were
still able to use the device but not
necessarily have sex why and it really
helped them and it really you know that
pry explains why I'm such a great
athlete because I masturbate a lot this
this explains everything no wonder I'm
good in the gym so yeah I did bring up
the fact that I like to date athletes I
have to go back and read I haven't
checked my Wikipedia I just saw that and
I saw that that's something that we have
in common because I love athletes and
I've talked about it and people are like
oh are you like a gold digger or
whatever and I'm like no it's cuz
they're hot as [ __ ] they have great
bodies there's competent that swag they
have like and that's it and they're busy
they're a limited time offer when
traveling through your town and their
team is playing you get the hang out and
you get to go home and sleep in your own
bed and you get to go to the games and
you get to go to the game what do you
know about this new Rams head coach is
he's single he is so cute I know that
the coaching coordinators that work
underneath him really like him and they
feel it's gonna be great for the Rams
which is awesome but we can do a little
what I need to do some research I try
what I like you know priests talking you
know I don't want to like follow you and
offend your significant other but if
you're single I'm gonna keep following
it unfollowing you and unfollow you and
following you until you realize that's
happening so that you I hate what guys
do that to me by the way cuz I noticed
there are certain guys that will follow
unfollow follow they're waiting for you
to follow them so they can DM you and
annoys the [ __ ] out of me but don't you
find with you I'm sure the minute you
follow if I follow someone usually they
follow back to talk that must happen and
I've stopped following what my rule used
to be if I met you in person I would
follow you so I would meet people at
trade shows or events and I'd follow him
and it was always fun but then you you
quickly have to unfollow them because
every day like today I just said to some
guy I go you know you're the twenty
seventh hundred DM I have this week
asking to go on a date with me I
again and I just cut and paste these
responses 2700 and a weird doc and I'm
like what do you what are you people
thinking like what are you people
thinking no you cannot ask me on a date
during Twitter uh like what and everyone
also what I don't like about the DM why
I don't answer Instagram DMS and why I
don't want to follow people back on
snapchat was like let's stop 101 how
much [ __ ] time do you people think I
have okay I heard him on social media
six to eight full hours a day did I have
a job then I home to take care of did I
have friends that I have a life that I
want to get a massage once why I want to
go to cryotherapy I want to go to the
gym can we one-on-one snap
what the [ __ ] purpose is this opens
brings on new chaos like Evans true it's
so needy I want your individual
attention listed read my [ __ ]
timeline like it or leave it
the funny thing is that I I try every
once in a while on Instagram or whatever
on Twitter people can't DM you unless
you follow them I only follow people I
know or want to sleep with so yeah but
on Instagram I do try every once a while
to just hit back one or two just cuz
sometimes there's good work stuff in
there like I'm so blown away how many
things but I miss what I do decide to
troll it I'm like oh yeah want me to
endorse this product and I didn't see it
for three months yeah I probably don't
trust in me anymore well and for you
it's like because you did porn for so
long it's probably different guys are
probably just hitting you up for dates I
get about pics and masturbation videos
by the way I get them selfies I get a
lot of dicks I get a lot of dicks but I
I tried to only answer the ones that are
like fans of my comedy like if a guy
writes to me and I'll watch they're all
gonna do this now but if a guy writes to
me he goes like you're so funny I saw
you at the Comedy Store I loved your set
whatever I'll send them back like thanks
but the problem is sometimes you once
you send one word it opens a floodgate
and they won't stop messaging you so now
I've kind of slowed down right here's
what you do in that situation so you
said no one word yeah and then the guy
just keeps coming at you with DMS I wait
until there's enough of a screen of just
his answers with none of my responses
then I screen grab it then i DM him and
I go do you see how lame that looks like
why the [ __ ] are you talking to yourself
in my DM box cuz I mean that's just put
that in I need your ad I'm - I'm a
little - I'm still a little too nice I'm
at the end of this road you're at the
beginning be nice you gotta do it
you gotta [ __ ] do it but he is it's
nice to everybody but but I want to talk
about you and okay so you got into the
porn industry then what year early 90s
early 90s so before that you were
married right - exactly married in my
90s so we talked about it because of
something similar we did but I took a
break from porn in 1997 because we had a
massive AIDS situation happened it
changed everything about my mindset and
I that week when it happened
I flew cross-country to do a booking in
Florida the driver that picked me up was
like weirdly love at first sight and
then to be honest in full disclosure we
did ecstasy for an entire week while I
was there so of course I fell in love
with him and then I went back to
California packed up my [ __ ] moved
cross-country after knowing this guy for
a week are you serious seven years
sometimes that happened
Gudrun and rode with me and we sight we
did all the sightseeing and wonderful
things was it at Graceland we did all
the stuff I didn't do when I traveled
alone so we'd a very amicable divorce we
still talk every year on our wedding
anniversary I don't believe in sharing
time like that with somebody and then
having a nasty exit unless they did
something bad for he and I it was just
like this isn't working we're not once
you start to grow up you just realized
your differences could be major
differences that you will always buck
bicker over yeah that's exactly what
happened with me my ex and we're still
friends and there was no crazy like no
wow oh and I hear people going through
these crazy things I'm just like it's
sad sad it's like okay guys you decided
to end it so you could stop this misery
why are you inflicting more misery on
each other I also though have a thing
where I have to be cool with everyone in
in my life
oh me too so every guy even guys I've
just slept with or guys that we've dated
for a minute or like even I had one
recently that was a horrible ending he's
actually in your business right now with
the tea we had a really bad ending
because long story short we were hanging
out for a while and I was talking about
him on here not by name just I would I
called him porn guy but uh it turned out
he had a girlfriend that I didn't know
about who listened to this podcast
that's not what I
when you lie to me because I tell guys
all the time like I know same thing be
on it oh you need I don't need some
[ __ ] keying my [ __ ] car okay I don't
need I don't need to be in the middle of
you're in sandy and you know what for me
I feel it's bad karma and of course you
know a lot of athletes over the years
have come at me that have been in
relationships and I can find out you're
married and I say to them you have to
understand something
I know you're still gonna [ __ ] around on
your wife but it's just not gonna be
with me because I'm date I say you want
to be in a relationship and I want to
have good karma coming to me and I don't
want to be that girl and there's enough
single dudes out there I'm the same I
had a guy recently I think it's
hilarious
by the way that okay so I didn't realize
that guy had a girlfriend but in the
back of my mind I had a feeling just the
way he was yeah but I had recently a
football player hit me up on Twitter
super cute we started talking a little
bit whatever and I have always had a
rule that I don't Google people cuz I
just I feel if I google me there's a lot
of misinformation or people will get the
wrong ideas so I will google to see your
Wikipedia page to see if you're married
guys well that's the thing I normally
don't Google people but I don't need to
because I have girlfriends are like
[ __ ] CIA spies and [ __ ] I tell them
I'm going on a date with someone they
send me their whole criminal record let
me know exactly where you're gonna be in
what time seriously so this guy asked me
out he's so cute and we start talking
he's funny too and then I told my
girlfriend I'm just kind of stoked to go
out with this guy he seems pretty dope
she goes I'm almost positive he's
married
she Google's him not only is he married
but he is on a reality show with his
wife like one of those football player
wife I'm like how [ __ ] dumb can you
be so of course then I was like hey are
you married like we can't go out if
you're married and he was like well yeah
I am but I'll tell you more about it on
the date and I was like no [ __ ] that
it's all it's one word that's all I need
yeah if you're married that is a line I
do not cross you can bring your wife out
on the date as well and let her give our
side of the story because there's two
people in that one word married that's
the best part when guys are like well
yeah I'm married but my wife we only
backtrack what happened with porn boy
well I've told it on here but I mean
long story short his it turned out he
had a girlfriend and and also I think a
another chick that was pregnant I'm not
sure all the details what I know is that
I found out
I said something about him on here
having a girlfriend I found out he had a
girlfriend and then also that he told me
he was having a kid with someone
this all happened at one time and then
apparently his girlfriend listens to
podcasts or something and and so she put
together who he was based on this
information but I don't think she knew
he was having a kid and so like I he
called me like freaking out but he was
like you destroyed my relationship and I
was like [ __ ] you I didn't know you had
a fact that you are single-handedly
destroying your relationship by cheating
on it okay so that's on you [ __ ]
don't blame me for getting quite a lie
like when people lie and then they get
caught and they're more mad about to the
person that sold them out than they are
the fact that you meet you lie
especially this because this is my thing
with men is I am the most chill chick if
you are a hundred percent straight up
with me right like I went out with this
guy one time I was into him I kind of
wanted to date him and he said to me on
the first date he said I'm not looking
to date anyone I just think you're
really hot and I think we could have
great sex and we have good chemistry and
if you're into that kind of thing
this could this could just be a chill
situation I swear no guy ever said
that's my face before just eyes yeah
because we're usually men or not that as
honest as women right exactly so when he
said that it was like a light bulb went
off in my head oh my god I know what
this is I can get into this knowing and
we could just have [ __ ] fun and we
did and we still do I still have my own
Oster members I got divorced when I was
30 I have roster members that have been
in my life in between all of their
relationships the whole time yeah its
roster it's my own personal fantasy team
you know they get shuffled around a
little bit I got my Benchwarmers my
starters it's also seasonal cuz remember
right now was just the changing of the
guards the football players were out
here for their offseason now the
basketball players are out here for
their offseason so you know they're a
good spot in LA for a lot of good great
house rentals that you get to visit and
lay at the pool yeah I uh I'm into that
speaking of catching someone about ten
years ago I caught someone lying to me
and it just so happened that he took
said girl to Vegas and he just so
happened that one of my friends saw him
and took
photo and sent it to me and I was like
oh this is interesting let me find out
who this girl is
and I bet you they flew for Southwest
I'm a very good friend that works for
Southwest I bet I can find out when
their flight is landing and I bet I
could be sitting at [ __ ] Burbank
Airport no you're not for them right
home to let her know who I was in this
situation just to be certain that I
could get it off my chest and and make
his face when he saw me standing there
oh my what are you doing here I'm like
oh you know it's interesting what are
you two doing where are you coming from
I got this really great photo of the two
of you two nights ago and it took me one
night to get a hold of Southwest and get
your wave info and Here I am so it was
the demise of them and the demise of us
so I felt like that's kind of the best
and that's my thing is I'm not
vindictive or petty unless someone lies
to me and then I will [ __ ] make it
like I was seeing this guy we weren't
exclusive
but I always ask guys if they're single
because I want to know if there's a girl
that's gonna come for me or you know
what I mean that's the thing yeah so I
asked him he's like I'm single we
started hanging out or hooking up one
day another guy I was dating which you
know I was dating multiple people know
non-exclusive yeah yes it's but this is
amazing another guy I was dating invites
me to a party at its house so I go this
dude I didn't know was friends with the
other guy so they're friends right so
that's cool I mean that doesn't really
bother me because I'm not exclusive with
either one at this point right a small
world we all know that even it's this
business especially if you hook up in
certain businesses yeah so the guy that
I was sleeping with it told me he was
single shows up at this party with his
nine months pregnant living alone ah
yeah so he walks in the whole situation
is like so [ __ ] weird because I'm
with the other guy that it turns out
they're friends he's with his nine
months pregnant girlfriend and then what
I decided to do of course is just make
like super good friends with the girl
like I hang out with his girlfriend
scares the bejesus out of them but
what's she gonna say what's she gonna
say or you look
over here we're talking it was amazing
like I could see him the whole time just
kind of like peeking over the corners I
like staring in eyes and I was like oh
how long guys been together you look
amazing what are you gonna name the baby
and he just the look of horror on his
face was great just making someone that
I but it's it's we got to send the
messages women that we're willing to be
we own our sexuality and we want to be
hooking up with other people and having
a good time we're free in our own self
we don't need to be going on formal
dates we don't need to be all this wine
and dine we're simple women right but
don't lie don't lie that's it that's it
and I know the way that you know you
said you're like me and you don't like
things at end poorly but sometimes it's
somebody else's fault true which brings
me to my Monday night yes tell me about
it so so you know about me with dating
dating and actually going out in public
is really tough because most people that
I'm going on a date with don't want to
be videoed and photographed the whole
time they're eating yeah and people
video and photograph me like I'm a
unicorn at a restaurant I mean it is so
hard to go out like it is so mine really
yeah and it's so interesting and ask him
for a photo like I can remember being on
a date in Miami and boy I'll walk up to
your day and ask him to care for them
how much they masturbate to me oh I love
that so going out in public doesn't work
so I have guys that just come over to my
house and I'm very firm with my schedule
and I'm like well listen I have Monday
from 9:30 to 11:30 available but I want
to be in the shower by 11:30 and I want
to be in bed by midnight have a busy
week this yeah so let's just make this
happen if you're gonna be crazy late
don't bother coming at all but give me a
heads up no no big deal he's 20 minutes
late but when he's 20 minutes late he
walks in and he's talking and I think
he's talking to me and he's on his phone
and he gives me the shoe thing and keeps
talking walks in my house proceeds to
get comfortable on the couch
no and keeps talking then he wants to
like start like you know touching me and
communicating with me in it while he's
on the phone if 10 minutes I looked in
but I said is there a death in your
family or are you being fired from your
job and he said no it's my sister you
know she's fighting with my mom I said
okay you know what you tell your sister
that you're gonna call her back in five
minutes when you leave I love it like
what I said tell your says so I knew she
could hear me on the phone you're gonna
call her back in five minutes when you
leave he gets off the phone he's like
you don't understand it's family I said
we all have different rules
you're not abiding by mine you don't
greet someone while you're on the phone
with someone else if a situation arose
you should have texted me and canceled
and showed me the respect ya [ __ ] busy
woman too
and I could have been on the phone with
somebody else I could have been working
on my blog I could have been doing [ __ ]
I could have been tweeting and answering
dick pic DMS and then he perceived in
shock and I'm like I'm not kidding he's
like oh come on we're just gonna because
I go I'm not gonna kiss somebody that
didn't even greet me you shush me in my
own [ __ ] house I already texted and
and cut and paste to all of my friends
what was going down of course
[ __ ] can and his number is
blocked and I'm not following a message
media how many times did you guys hung
out before this is only our third that
is so annoying
thank you that happened to me with a guy
I went to a guy's place he invited me
over I was like the same exact thing I
had a crazy day I had an early morning
the next day I was like I'm gonna come
over at 9:00 I gotta be out of there by
like 12 I came in he was on the phone
for like 40 minutes on the phone didn't
even get up to say hi and I didn't like
write you a note I post it like you're
it was like somebody normal would it be
like I have an emergency call here just
to fill you in on what's going on my
thing is I'm like you knew I was coming
why didn't you say come at 10:00 instead
I could have done something else for an
hour that but this leads me to a great
point that I want to talk about actually
this is really this is something that's
really irritating me in this [ __ ]
town is guys have a thing about not
respecting your time like guys don't
want to make plans ever guys don't want
to set a time I was just texting with
this guy that I was supposed to go out
with this uh this dude we're trying to
make plans should keep dating huh cuz
you have to have stories Wow keeps
shooting yeah go on as many dates as I
can for this podcast I go on at least
like one or two a week but every once a
while I like one you know
mara mental yeah yeah but I was supposed
to go out with this guy he's hot as [ __ ]
we've been out before I like him we but
the thing is this [ __ ] will not
make plans it's the other day were
texting I think was Sunday I'm like
let's hang tomorrow night and he goes
okay yeah we can play by ear I'll hit
you up tomorrow I'm like no [ __ ]
tomorrow's tomorrow if you don't know
yeah if you can hang out tomorrow night
then we're not hanging out I don't
understand I respond back with this you
do realize it's raining dick in my life
like it is raining dick in my life all
the time and when you say to me Oh we'll
play it by ear
yeah the ear this could be played with
is not yours it's gonna be the dude that
said yes tomorrow works I am continuing
going through my phone this it is so
true and I don't think that like my my
friend has this thing she says if a guy
takes three hours to text me back I've
already text with four other guys by
then like it's I mean there's guys don't
understand how how many men are coming
out women at any given time I learned
something when I first moved out here I
was in the car with an old director who
passed away a couple years ago Fred
Lincoln who I love to work with and he
treated me like family he was just such
a great guy and he looked at me in the
car one day and he said you do you know
something Lisa he said with one of those
you can get as many of these as you want
so what do you meant was with the vagina
he gets many dicks as you want he's like
so don't don't fuss over just one and I
was like all right Freddy I was so young
I was like maybe 20 21 years old I was
like that theory stayed in my mind like
yeah he's right with my vagina I can get
as many penises as I want why am i
[ __ ] around but the time thing I
think in LA especially men do not look
at us as equals when it comes to the
fact that we're grinding our careers as
well we're staying on social media we've
got to do PR for the events that we do
we were constantly going and we have
friendships as well that we'd like to
see and things that we want to do so
when it's like oh well you know we'll
play it by ear I'll see you tomorrow
it's like no because I'm actually lining
up tomorrow right now anyway hitting you
[ __ ] yeah exactly
and then you start to feel like the man
like my girlfriend was giving me so much
[ __ ] today because she's like you have
to stop being the one to make play cuz
I'm always the one that will say to a
guy like can you do this time at this
time
she's like you got to stop being the man
and I'm like I know but I find that
they'll never do it oh you have to do it
that way cuz you're organizing your
schedule she says no cuz there's gonna
be one two bites there's gonna be one
that bites they all bite if you just do
it yeah you just feel ask them they
usually bite but that okay so this is
I've been getting messages lately and
people are like so on the podcast we
always just tell stories and stuff but
I've been getting messages from people
who are like we want some advice also
like cuz a lot of guys listen so let me
ask you that his first start like what
how can a guy I mean you're in a special
category because of what you do but what
do you think is the most attractive way
for a guy to approach a woman if they're
interested just basic conversation and
manners like to me I can see someone's
manners by their approach and if there
are kind genuine person why wouldn't you
carry on that conversation with them but
it's just the guys are so abrupt and
they're also so awkward you know and so
when they're when they're not being
awkward they're like toying with their
phone they're doing whatever they can to
have their little mechanisms that you
know but they like they like feel that
everything they do should be a
panty-dropper and it's like you know no
like I've hooked up with regular guys
that I've met that we've just had a
great talk about a game that was on at
the bar and it's like we had this great
talk he seemed nice maybe we had some
more conversation like don't go for the
kill
in the first interaction if you're chill
especially when you're a girl that's
used to getting hit on often the guys
that are just chill I was out with a guy
the other night
and uh we definitely have a lot of like
sexual chemistry but he was like being
super aggressive and I said right to my
go can you chill just chill I get when
guys like come on too fast with me I get
really even if I'm into them even if
they're super hot unless I'm like you
know drunk and coked up or something but
I mean like normally I I like guys to be
chill and just take their time and relax
like that makes me relax I agree with
you and you know I put notes in the note
section of the phone so I know what
category each guy is in some guys I will
not like once in a while I will go out
to eat with a guy you know but some guys
I will not go out to eat with because
the way they interact with others and
the way they talk it's such a turn-off
that then I think oh my god so much
just happened I might not want to [ __ ]
him but I really still would have [ __ ]
them because I love having sex them so
sometimes I look at that guy and I'm
like he is only the guy that comes from
9:30 to 11:30 he is never yeah because
you know whether they're abrupt with the
server where they feel like you like
listen we're not planning a family here
if you don't really like your food it's
not the end of the world like you know
it she was so funny you know my favorite
thing to do on dates so if a date isn't
going well I do this my first time when
I was 16 at a Red Lobster at the Lehigh
Valley Mall parking lot I climbed out
the bathroom window with my best friends
and we left our date at the table that's
let's path flash-forward I'm 45 now so
since then 29 rich years of living this
life I have probably walked out on a
hundred dates and it's become so bad at
the Mastro's in Beverly Hills that I
haven't gone there for a year because
the last couple times I went in there
like are you staying tonight you know
cuz I will tell my date I'm going the
bathroom I always keep my keys with me I
never let them pick me up and I just
bail and I just walked down the street
hide away and get my uber and go the
[ __ ] home oh well I don't have to it at
Mastro's you can sneak down those stairs
like there's certain tables that they
know I don't want cuz I don't want to be
in vision of any doorways I would like
to be back in an area where it could
look like I'm walking to the bathroom
but I'm really walking out that [ __ ]
door cuz you've just killed it and if
I'm not gonna have sex with you then
you're useless to me I can go home make
my own food I have a grill you know I
mean I buy steaks oh my god so yeah I
love to walk out and I think it's a
lesson because then I do have the talk
with them the next day of why I walked
out you explained it I do what's your
typical reason I don't like anyone who's
rude to servers same I don't want a guy
who's at a restaurant on his [ __ ]
phone listen you're not a heart surgeon
because I don't date heart surgeons I
haven't met anyone that intelligent
that's interested in me so I'm dating
regular dudes or athletes like nothing
is changing to your game tomorrow
there's no need for you to be on your
phone that annoys me and just when
people are loud like what the one of the
times I did this at Mastro's we were at
the small table and there was another
table so close and the guy was just
using a ton of profanity and there were
like other people around and I look to
make oh you know what like this couple
over here looks like they probably all
come out here very often I'm sure they
don't want to hear you're potty mouth
let's just try and like chill it a
little bit
No yeah I don't like the aggressive
aggressive to me is aggressive behavior
and the last but not least if I know
more about your ex on my first date with
you then I don't I know about you I'm
[ __ ] done yeah totally so you could
tell they're still hell-bent on it oh
you know she did this just TMI buddy oh
yeah yeah that would drive me insane
yeah it's like I haven't taken
antibiotics and two and a half years
since I retired from porn like I throw
[ __ ] like that back to them the same
it's [ __ ] irrelevant it doesn't matter
I don't like when people ask me about my
exes either like I don't understand why
people ask I mean I understand asking
like have you been married how many
serious relationships have you if you're
trying to be in a relationship but like
when people ask questions about like who
you've slept with or I just think that's
weird
I think her cares I don't give a [ __ ]
what anybody does before me it doesn't
doesn't matter to me unless you have
herpes or something I need to know about
that I have nine kids that if we get in
a serious relationship I may be having
to pick up some the child support that
[ __ ] I want to know maybe you know what
I mean yeah kids are a thing I was just
dating a guy that I was real into and he
had kids and I don't mind if you have
kids but it just it makes it really hard
to get together cuz he would have his
kids on the weekend here's the thing I
love calendar dad's calendar dads are
single dads who have custody joint
custody of their kids what I love about
it is I can plan all my other sexcapades
cuz their money has has collapsed out in
advance you know every other weekend
your [ __ ] break it's like all right I
know next week it in and the weekends
that they don't have their kids they're
in they want to go out they want to eat
they want to Tracy that would be good
this guy had his kids every weekend and
like the only time I could really see
him is on the weekends cuz he didn't
live too close so it was just it was
involved geographically unfit yeah I was
a problem Ark this is so hot Oh anyway
so this is something I've never talked
about on here but this is something that
just happened it's so funny so I have a
bar that I always take first dates to
like yeah any time a guy is like you
pick the spot I picked the same spot I
do that with mexicali in studios you do
I'm not gonna say where mine is
I don't want people showing up like are
you wanna do but so I love this bar
because it's a hole in the wall
but it's cute and I never see anyone I
know there and the bartender now she got
it figured out cuz I come in there like
once a week with a different guy you
know so so this past week I went on a
first date at this bar and I'll talk
about the guy but the funny thing is at
the end of the night the guy went to the
bathroom the bartender leans over to me
and goes hey if it doesn't work out with
this one can I get his number
like pre-screening yeah you get in my
trash I mean honestly I was like what a
great I mean why not like I totally
women's group we need to start a woman's
group like this we can swap right oh my
god that'd be holy to girlfriends that
have the same tasted me that lived one
one in New York one in Miami and we
share guys all the time so it's like
what if my Miami girls friends will be
in LA he's like oh so it's those in LA
for the next week you guys want to hook
up and I already know he's not gonna
kill me cuz I reference so I'm like yeah
for sure
I'm all over to his hotel I'm curious
about this too like what about chemistry
because like there are lots of I find
that there are lots of guys I look at
I'm like he's so hot but only maybe one
in ten I have a crazy chemistry with and
I'm so picky that if I don't have it I
don't want to [ __ ] them yeah I can agree
with that too but there's something
different with me because there's this
excitement factor that they've watched
tape and that they're actually gonna get
to experience what I experienced yeah so
there's this enthusiasm that normally
comes naturally which like mr. Monday
night I when he called me on his bride
home to try and talk his way off the
ledge I said to him you know I'm gonna
chalk this up as a missed opportunity
for you and you might want to go out
there and tell your guy friends exactly
who I am and exactly what you did had
you guys never had sex
we'd had sex twice before okay it was
great but I don't really like him as a
person he annoys me but the sex is
amazing that's so beautiful I know
that's why I would never go out with him
in public see and I'd have to talk to
him I can't have great sex with someone
that I don't kinda like like oh that's
not entirely true I mean there have been
guys that I liked a little at the
beginning
and then by the end I wanted to kill
them which made me want to [ __ ] him even
more I find the more I want to kill a
guy the more I want to [ __ ] him
I think porn really trained me to be
able to separate in carp metal you know
compartmentalize things a bit because I
didn't have to really love what the guy
was about I had to love how we perform
together so it was really just about the
sexual factor and everything else about
him could be chaos like there's a guy in
the biz there's quite a few guys in the
business that have been to jail for
multiple things right there's a prison
deck there's love prison dicks by the
way you know when you ask a guy in the
business when you interview a porn star
you say to him how do you get it up for
a girl that's like you know not so hot
and you're not into her and they're like
I just think about I was in prison for
10 years and she's my first piece of ass
shut up I had to look past some of the
things that in my personal life I may be
like I'm not so sure I want to be with a
murderer look how different we are
you're like I wouldn't date a murderer
I'm like send me to prison dick
I love reformed convicts that's my
favorite kind of guy I oh my god they're
the best if they're a little reformed
okay anyway go on okay no youyou that
was that ID so now I'm like My Mind's
like huh okay yeah so yeah the
connections important but not as
important for me because I've been able
to separate the two and say I don't
really like having too much small talk
with this guy but I do love his penis no
I get that I mean there are definitely a
couple guys that I've had that way it's
funny because there was a porn guy that
I actually hooked up with a few times we
just hooked up we probably slept with
like several listening he's great in bed
like amazing and if I really liked him
it would probably be like the best sex
in my life but because I I like him as a
friend I really like him as a friend I
like him as a person there's nothing I
don't like about him but I don't I'm not
into him yeah too much right which keeps
the sex for me like great like nice like
I would do it again but I'm not lusting
over it you yeah changed plans last
minute to go get it
you would sketch exactly ads but if it
came into town last minute you wouldn't
change plans there are those guys that
if they come in last minute you change
plans buddy
weird because it's like that is about
how much I like him about my feelings
for him right so it's weird that like
for me that how good he is technically
and how good he looks doesn't
necessarily mean like fire and another
thing I realized with the guys is
sometimes the best sex is definitely the
guy you should not be with every time
when it's the best way ever I'm like I
know this is gonna end poorly and I
should probably just it's I just said
this to a guy there's this guy I've been
talking to I'm really into him but
literally the first night I met him I
already felt the chemistry we didn't
even we hung out for maybe five minutes
the first night like the minute I hugged
him I was like oh [ __ ] I could just tell
and I said to him I go it makes me not
want to date you because I know from my
track record to any guy I'm that
attracted to immediately it's gonna ruin
my life no there's something wrong right
there like the Burger King of my
fast-food situation you know the
commercial looks great but it's gonna do
horrible things in my body
he's gonna ruin my body I'm not doing it
I'm not doing it I'm trying so hard to
date guys that are boring and will be
good for my life and it's just that's it
now I'm trying to turn this dating
situation are you looking for an actual
relationship where you like your life
the way it is right now you know what's
funny is this is the thing all I really
want is because I've been married so I'm
not looking to get married again and I
don't want kids I didn't either so I
knew that right away so that kept me
from jumping into being into serious
relationships yeah and then for a while
I was really happy just being single but
lately I'm not gonna lie I kind of what
I want is just some stability with a guy
because I'm this business goes so much
like this and my life is so chaotic and
to have someone worth the end of the
night after a rough day I can just go
there and curl up with that person yeah
I kind of missed that I get it so it's
weird because it's like it's I don't
need much like I don't I don't need guys
that take me out on fancy dinners I
don't care about money or cars or all
that dumb [ __ ] or shopping together or
vacations it's really just for me like
about having a place that's like oh I
can relax yeah
at a separate spot and we go through
phases where you feel that way and then
you realize oh I don't feel that way
anymore I'm glad I didn't get into a
serious relationship like you know like
for me it's like I tell my friends like
when I'm ready again for a relationship
now I was divorced at 30 I have he's the
only guy I've ever lived with and I
really haven't been in a serious
relationship since him I've been in one
since my divorce but it was like a
rebound relation
so that's it my rebound relationships
for the list of all the people that I
knew if I wasn't married I would [ __ ]
and I went through them on I got you
while I was married like there was this
guy hot chuck from the gym and we were
like you know all of all married women
were like as soon as you get divorced
you gotta have sex with it but tell us
how it is he was like he still lived at
home oh that's how but he was over 18
let me just clarify that I like to be
legit on that but I tell my friends like
when I'm ready for a relationship and
when I try and tell you this because I
didn't experiment this February and
there's a guy that I've been dating
casually for about ten years and now he
finally moved out here for the first
time and it was our first time ever
living in the same city we've always
lived cross country and just seen each
other like four or five times a year but
like kept in touch this and that and so
we did a trial run and he stayed at my
house for two weeks it was a nightmare
and I rely told my friends next time I
feel that urge I'm just gonna get a dog
really yeah because it was annoying he
was in my space and I didn't like and it
wasn't enough great and you know what
once you're with somebody regularly like
they do get comfortable so fastness oh
yeah I'm just like like standard like
just rolling over one position sex it's
like okay we're on the two week mark and
we're having one position sex I fear for
my [ __ ] future this has to end
oh my god that sounds off yeah no I
don't even want to live with somebody I
don't think I just wanna you know what I
want I just want to open invitation
that's what I want I want to open
invitation so it's not that awkward like
what are you doing today like I just
want an open invitation so at the end of
the night I can just like if I want to
come I can or I can go home like
basically what I really wanted is
whatever I want what I want is whatever
I want what I want is like I just want
to have it
my way all the time and I don't think
that's gonna work out good might work
out you just never know get yourself
like a pilot somebody that you know he's
only home half the month and you could
work it in I mean lately I don't know
what I'm doing but lately I have a lot
of great options and I'm going out a lot
I'm meeting a lot of hot guys and
everything is great if you get into a
relationship
what's the podcast gonna be about I know
it's gonna ruin my whole career because
I'm so bad at everything that I'll
probably [ __ ] that up too and then I'll
have great [ __ ] you know what I mean
I'll have to talk about that's true
before we go we only have a few minutes
this one's so fast you're so great I
love having on people that can talk yeah
I'm the one-word answer interview and
you're like oh great I went through my
ten questions with you and it's always
17 after I've had this happen when I've
interviewed people I'm like can't you do
better like can't you elaborate at all
it's the worst also people that come on
this show and don't want to talk about
sex and dating and I'm like did you not
get the gist of what this is before you
came yeah that's always interesting to
like you don't ever check what you're
doing yeah could have taken you into a
you could have walked across coals today
but tell me this I always ask people for
like their worst date or worst sex just
like the worst is there anything you can
think of that was just like an awful I
mean you had one the other night it was
a pretty good date fair it was a pretty
good date fail that was actually a
pretty good date fail okay here's a good
date fell guys taking me to a Lakers
game he's late how do you be show up
late to go to a game okay and then
you're gonna sit in traffic not only is
he late I hate it when guys text me from
outside and like leave their car running
and sit there I prefer if you call in or
at least get up and get out of your car
and open the door doesn't open the door
the real date fail was this he was
wearing a powder blue Leisure Suit and
this is a black man at six seven who
could be [ __ ] spectacular and now I'm
over the fact that he was late missed
the first quarter and I'm ashamed that
we don't get into a car accident because
I am going to stand out and probably be
on the kiss-cam
with my powder blue Easter M&M okay and
it was was he wearing it like as
joke to me funny I thought he was swaggy
and you know white shoes and like the
whole game I was just like I need to
swap it was one of those days where I
walked in a staple center ran into
everybody I know and then he ends the
date on the third quarter by saying
let's get out of here early so we missed
traffic on it we never dated again I
didn't even let him in the house that
night I didn't even I didn't even put
out I was just like you know what you
were late and then you want to leave
early so he really only saw half the
game and it was half enough for me to be
scarred by your blue leisure suit you're
like that's a given if you just don't
[ __ ] up completely the other night when
I was texting my girlfriends I said he
either needs to shut up put out or get
out those are his three choices right
now with this uncle oh my god you're so
funny I love you you're amazing I want
to be you I think that we need to hang
out more
do I think you I think you'll bring me
out of my shell a little bit and it
sounds like you know a lot of the guys
that I would like to know so we and we
don't pull some tail together dude and
then when you give me the wink cuz
you're too nice yeah I can do the
cutthroat moves that I like to do like I
bet you share a Netflix password with
your roommate we're gonna do guys Lisa
and you've been amazing thank you so
much for being here please get her
booked the life which actually she
brought me two extra copies so I'll do
something where I'll give away two extra
copies too you guys ought to figure out
how I'll tweet something will tweet a
photo or something like that
so make sure you guys check out her book
the life anything else you want to plug
your XM radio show Sirius XM fantasy you
can see all my schedule on my timelines
at the real Lisa and and I'm dropping a
blog tonight at midnight and it is built
and I've been working on it for a month
and I've gone through 25 years of photos
on hard drive and on disk so I had about
a armor course and I'm doing a lot of
everyday daily blogging but I'm also
doing history of my entire time
traveling and being in the business
that's gonna be hot I'm going through
the mall oh my god I'm sure Lisa and
guys follow her at the Rio Lisa and you
guys know me I'm Kate follow me at Kate
cue funny and check out the patreon
patreon com
backslash KQ funny and make sure you
I subscribe to all things comedy on
YouTube you guys are the best thanks for
listening bye hi you're awesome